sanctions a bit like this piece of art
can split opinion at this gallery in
london's mayfair the director suggests a
ban on exporting luxury goods may punish
the wrong people
the one or two individuals russian
individuals that i've spoken to
have
you know condemned the war and and have
been
quite vocal
alons says there are ways around this
ban
the wealthier russian clients that we
know
will have
multiple homes all over the world
and if as i understand it the ban is
just on luxury goods
entering russia
i think it will be fairly
er you should it'll be a fairly useless
ban because they will simply buy the
goods for other homes around the world
uk exports to russia were worth 193
million pounds in january alone and 3
billion pounds in all of 2021.
it is an important point of principle
that we send this signal to putin's
kremlin that they cannot be living this
mayfair lifestyle in moscow whilst the
atrocities continue in ukraine
but the government also has to put in
place appropriate support for those
businesses that are affected to ensure
they can find new markets for their
products
the list of items included in the ban is
vast from high-end fashion to musical
instruments luggage sports equipment and
even horses
britain isn't alone in this the g7
countries and the world trade
organization are all working together to
further isolate russia from global trade
the idea is to ensure russia doesn't
benefit from the rules-based
international system that they say it
doesn't respect
some businesses didn't wait for it to be
official
we took a stance quite early on to stop
dealing in russian diamonds and to stop
that in any way that we could do
the uk has already sanctioned
high-profile russian individuals phased
out russian oil imports and imposed
additional tariffs on the import of
russian goods and this the latest
measure aimed at starving president
putin's war machine
sadia chowdhury sky news